Everybody Poops hi I'm Katy Perry and
I'm here with BuzzFeed to play with
puppies I'm so excited
I've got tears
I'll smell my puppy I didn't even bring
my puppy because I knew that I needed to
give you all of my love hi hi how old
are you
why do we all talking Little Voices
oh they smell so good they're small
little animals full of love listen I was
not a dog person until I got a dog
oh you're gonna step in it and then
you're gonna go on me are you licking
your brother's peepee that's weird oh I
have a child I do this all day
especially since we're potty training
there's two
yeah
who let the dogs
I would not sing that song but that's a
great why are you humping your sister I
would sing what if God was one of us by
Joan Osborne because I love the lyrics
and I think it has a lot of ability to
Showcase vocals and play with Dynamics
and it shows off who a person is I think
as an artist when they pick kind of
specific songs I probably play my guitar
oh you want to stay here you love me
this is the one that's chosen me
[Music]
probably being a woman and having a
strong opinion
I also think that what's really
challenging is that only one person wins
this contest and I would say that like
the top 20 are all superstars and I
would never want to sing after them
because they can also sing better than
all of us so it's it's challenging that
people really great people
have to leave the competition it's just
not fear
being able to help people find their
spark inside of them their purpose to be
able to help nurture and Mentor that
spark into something because I think a
lot of people come on on the show at an
audition and it's a little bit like
either their mom signed them up or it's
on a whim or they just want to like be
brave but they don't really know if like
they're chosen for this profession and
then sometimes we get to see and confirm
and tell them oh
hey hey hey hey hey calm down that's me
and Luke on the show we just basically
get to Mentor and nurture them and it's
amazing to be able to give them kind of
a lottery ticket to their life and their
life's purpose and set them on their way
and they get to put people on their path
and it's so beautiful and all the
puppies have left
oh they're all behind me
[Music]
Luke and I loved pranking Lionel a lot
in the beginning Seasons I mean he sat
literally on an old school whoopee
cushion it's amazing for all of us to
watch someone grow like a contestant
grow in such short amount of time and
for them to really like get what they
came for which sometimes they don't even
know what they came for they think they
want to win but maybe winning isn't what
they're supposed to get from this
contest maybe they're supposed to
understand their self-worth maybe
they're supposed to just feel
unconditionally loved for the very first
time
[Music]
one song just one song out of the old
kid caboodle I mean I wouldn't want to
steal it from any other artists because
that wouldn't be kind because you know
once an artist sings on something they
kind of make it their own but I would
say there's been I've had I've written a
lot of songs that haven't made records
and some of them have been recorded by
other artists like Kelly Clarkson and
Selena Gomez and Britney Spears like I
wrote them for an element but you can
only put so many songs on and then you
have all these songs left over and then
they find homes like these puppies will
find homes are these puppies going to be
finding homes
yes I am very organized thankfully
because of my team so yeah fight let's
go
[Music]
all that to say I'm very excited for the
next thing and I'm still doing my
residency for the rest of this year and
it will end November 4th so there's only
a few shows actually every ending has a
new beginning
[Music]
my favorite moment from my residency is
seeing it all to come together in the
most chaotic of times every night is so
fun because I get to bring two people on
the stage it's like a sweepstakes and
you donate to my firework foundation and
you can get randomly picked to be on
stage that night and then I just
randomly picked someone in the audience
it's hilarious we've had the craziest
people on stage a lot a lot of people
that are getting married some you know
drag queens Northwest you know
lots of variety
[Applause]
yes she does also sometimes she comes to
work with me and she says mommy's
singing Mommy I want to see Mommy
singing Mommy Mommy I come I come see
Mommy singing I sing a few songs to her
every night but I sing You Are My
Sunshine and I change the lyrics You are
my sunshine my only sunshine you make me
happy every day I know you know dear how
much I love you and it'll never go away
see there's no great days and you're not
never gonna know and it's never gonna go
away
I like to go out to eat because some of
the best restaurants in the world
actually a lot of the best restaurants
in the world in Las Vegas have
residencies in Vegas so there's always
pop-ups there's always chefs I love to
eat I love Carbone it's actually a great
place called cover steak Jose Andreas
has a really cool kind of theatrical
restaurant we went to the other day so
we do that and then also I go and see
shows as well I really want to see a
Dell show
but we actually played on this play on
the same nights typically so I asked her
if she wanted to like swap like Parent
Trap and she said yeah maybe so if you
come to see me maybe one Friday or
Saturday may not be me
I oh yes I love them all I love the
First Act a lot there's a huge rocking
chair that I sing Dark Horse on are you
chewing on my cargo pant oh it's a fun
game now your brothers and sisters love
it I don't know it's not that I don't
love singing Roar because Roar and
Firework are at the end and everybody's
favorite and they're the best and stuff
it's just it's hard to reinterpret songs
sometimes every time you do a tour to
keep them feeling fresh some songs are
harder to remix than others
[Music]
oh poopies don't touch it don't eat it
don't step on it Everybody Poops
sometimes
honestly there's like Glam like looking
beautiful and looking Glam but having
the most fun and getting the most
attention was when I was a cheeseburger
my only regret is that that costume was
so like padded and like secure I could
have rolled myself down
the matte stairs and been okay but I
don't know if I'd ever get invited back
I spice
the boys are like yeah
[Music]
probably roulette or Legendary Lovers
yeah they should have done more for
those songs
I probably work in fashion of some sort
or be a costume designer I love clothes
I love presentation I love design but I
also love politics too I like politics
when they're like purposeful and making
and creating real change and helping
people if politics were
more pure maybe I would be a politician
[Music]
doesn't matter how bad of a day you have
you just like see your child and they
love you for who you are and not what
you do or what you give them unless it's
like a mango fruit leather she does love
those and she loves me for giving them
to her one of my favorite things to do
though is sometimes I'll be able to come
home after like a Wednesday show I will
come home with like full play makeup and
hair and I'll just pop my robe on and
I'll make her school lunch in the
kitchen at like 11 30 after doing a show
and that's what makes me feel really
complete is I'm making these school
lunches because I didn't have great
lunches and I had nothing to trade and
not that I'm gonna give her you know
stuff that's not great for her but I'm
gonna give her some good alternative
trading stuff oh my God
on a good granola bar it's like there
were two of them I'm sorry I'm yelling
the honey oat things you know the things
in the green I got those that's what I
got and they were so dry they were so
dry and broken in the package just like
the Ritz cheese crackers why can't you
put your cheese and your crackers
together anymore
adding you
okay next
[Music]
when you meet someone remember they may
not know exactly what you said to them
or whatever or they may not remember
specifically that but people always
remember how you made them feel keep
that in mind when you're meeting people
and I try and keep that in mind when
meeting everyone because I've met a
couple of my heroes and they were back
in the day and they weren't exactly like
all that I had dreamed them up to be and
I would never want that to be the case
for anyone that got to meet me because I
may only meet them once and nobody knows
what anyone's going through and
everybody's a story and everybody's
having a tough day sometimes and so
confession
lizzo I'd like lizzo to come and join
American Idol this is Luke this is an
invitation from me Katy Perry lizzo I'm
asking you to join the panel I'm feeling
a little outnumbered on the testosterone
I could really use some bold honest hot
takes
goodness gracious I don't know there's
so many I think that one of the songs
that I wrote for a couple albums back
called by the grace of God was really
important for some of the fans because
it was about some of my hardest times in
getting through it and so I think some
people listen to that and use it as
inspiration to get through their tough
times this one is really taking a liking
not moves a lot of the time maybe going
home with me
[Music]
when nugget was a puppy she was smaller
than this she was probably half the size
of these puppies and I got her and I put
her in my hand I literally held her and
she looked like a long chicken tender
and if you squinted your eyes or had two
beers she would look like a chicken
tender and also to be honest like I
would say that my taste buds have
evolved a little bit more but in the
past I mostly ordered off of the child
menu
oh
that's cool a cool question guys chill
out back there
you're not going anywhere it's not The
Truman Show
maybe Carrie Underwood just because I
haven't done a collab with any female
country stars yet I did a song with
Thomas Rhett which was really fun but
um she's like Queen of country so that's
cool and she's glam
guys
this one loves me it's
awesome and if you want it oh thank you
BuzzFeed for letting me answer questions
with puppies in hand I'd like to do that
every single day and I'd probably say a
lot more things that you guys want to
hear because I had no idea what I just
said because I was just focused on the
puppies you can adopt these puppies
actually just go to the hit living
Foundation watch Idol the puppies are
not going to be on American Idol but the
contestants are kind of like our little
baby puppies too
[Music]
thank you